Hallo, guten Tag. Mein Name ist Keisal Götters. Ich bin die zuständige Erstimpfüße.
Bevor wir zu Ihren Bescheiden kommen, lassen Sie mich ein paar Informationen über Sie notieren.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Ich heiße Michael Schröder.
Michael Schröder. Könnten Sie Ihr von und nach nach melangsam und kurz buchten?
Ich habe es Ihnen doch gesagt. Warum soll ich das noch mal buchstabieren?
Ja, richtig zu schreiben.
Okay, gut. Also, M-I-C-H-A-E-L, Michael.
Ja, genau.
Und Schröder, W-S-C-H-R-Ö-D-E-R.
Schröder.
Okay. Herr Schröder, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 56 Jahre alt.
Wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin geboren am 15. September 1966.
Wie groß und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin so ungefähr 76 groß und ungefähr 86 kg schwer.
Okay, danke schön. Und was sind Sie vom Beruf?
Ich bin ein IT-Spezialist.
IT-Spezialist.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstadt?
Ein Einrad.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe eine Tochter und einen Sohn.
Ja, sehr schön. Danke schön für die Informationen.
Herr Schröder, was kann ich für Sie tun?
Was haben Sie im Moment bescheiden?
Also, ich habe seit ungefähr 3-4 Wochen gemerkt,
ich habe zunehmend Rückenschmerzen
und mir schläft die Hand ein.
Rückenschmerzen und?
Meine rechte Hand schläft ein.
Rechte Hand.
Haben Sie Grippe oder Taubheizgefühl?
Wie gesagt, Taubheiz in der rechten Hand,
aber Grippe habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie einen Unfall gehabt?
Nein, keinen Unfall.
Sie haben schon gesagt,
leiden Sie unter Bewegungsanschleinkungen?
Wenn die Hand ein bisschen taub ist,
ich arbeite am Computer und kann nicht so richtig schreiben.
Ich merke, ich mache Fehler
und ich kann meine Finger nicht so richtig bewegen.
Gut bewegen, ja.
Haben Sie eine Verstechwerbung oder eine Rötung bemerkt?
Nein, keine.
Sie haben schon gesagt,
Rückenschmerzen, leiden Sie unter Rückenschmerzen.
Wie ist Ihre Rückenschmerzen?
Wo sind die Schmerzen?
Zwischen den Rippen,
obere Wirbelsäule.
Obere Wirbelsäule.
Wie ist Ihre Schmerzen?
Auf einer Schmerzkelle von 1 bis 10.
1, der leicht und 10, 6 Teil Schmerzen entspricht.
Überwiegend, zwischen 3 und 4,
aber hin und wieder, habe ich auch Schmerzen, die 5, 6 sein können.
5, 6 manchmal.
Könnten Sie genau beschreiben, wie die Schmerzen sind?
Sind Sie drückende, brennende oder dumpfende Schmerzen?
Das sind mehr so dumpfe Schmerzen,
in der Wirbelsäule,
wenn ich mich manchmal hinlegen muss,
wenn ich etwas länger stehe,
dann merke ich, ich tut das mehr weh.
Haben Sie dagegen etwas gemacht oder als Medikament?
Hin und wieder habe ich mal eine Ibuproféin 400 eingenommen,
aber die helfen auch nur sporadisch,
kurze Zeit, dann sind die Schmerzen wieder da.
Nicht ganz weg.
Ich verstehe.
Sie sollten immer sitzen bei der Arbeit oder auch der Arbeit.
Ich arbeite am Computer, mal von zu Hause,
Homeoffice, aber meistens auch im Büro,
das ist eine sitzende Arbeit.
Treiben Sie Sport dagegen oder bewegen Sie sich?
Ich mache eigentlich regelmäßig Sport.
Ich gehe mehrmals in Fitnessstudio, ich jogge,
aber das fällt mir in letzter Zeit schwer.
Besonders die Bewegungen haben Sie gemacht?
Für Ihre Wirbelsäule, Gesundheit oder was?
Ganz normale Fitnessstudio,
man macht so ein Fitnessstudio,
man macht so spezielle Training.
Leiden Sie unter Kopfschmerzen
oder haben Sie irgendwelche andere Beschwerden?
Nein, Kopfschmerzen oder Schwindel habe ich nicht.
Würden Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, nicht mehr.
Danke schön.
Herr Schröder, ich würde gerne über Vorerkrankungen fragen.
Leiden Sie an krönchen Erkrankungen.
Ich meine Bluthochdruck, Zuckerkrankheit oder erhöhte Blutwertwerte
oder irgendwelche Probleme beim Büro-Säule?
Bist du noch nicht bekannt gewesen?
Oder für Ihr wichtiges Vorerkrankungen gehabt?
Ich meine, müssten Sie ins Krankenhaus behandeln oder was?
Nein.
Ich habe nicht daran erinnern, dass ich im Krankenhaus gelegen habe
oder zum Arzt nicht gewesen musste.
Sind Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ja, als kleines Kind haben Sie mit den Mandeln rausgenommen,
aber mehr auch nicht.
Sind Sie gegen Covid-19 geimpft?
Ja, klar. Mittlerweile viermal.
Und in Ihrer Familie gibt es wichtige Erkrankungen?
Ich meine gleich. Erhöhte Blutwertwerte oder Zuckerkrankheit
oder Krebsfälle in Ihrer Familie?
Meine Mutter hatte mal Brustkrebs gehabt
und mein Vater hatte ein Altersdiabetes,
aber mehr wüsste ich jetzt nicht.
Aber leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Ja, noch leben.
Haben Sie Schwester?
Ich habe noch eine Schwester.
Ist sie gesund?
Sie ist gesund, der geht gut.
Die ist jünger als ich, der hat keine Probleme.
Okay, ist der schon.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Oder pülen Sie sich fieblich?
Das habe ich nicht so kontrolliert.
Aber ich merke, ich bin nicht mehr so leistungsfähig.
Seit drei, vier Wochen fühle ich mich schlapp.
Ich bin nicht mehr so leistungsfähig.
Sie sind momentan leistungsfähig.
Ja, ich bin nicht mehr so leistungsfähig.
Ich bin nicht mehr so leistungsfähig.
Momentan leistungsfähig.
Es geht.
Ich bin nicht so leistungsfähig wie früher.
Schlafen Sie gut?
Schlafen habe ich keine Probleme.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Appetit ist gut.
Ich kann ganz normal essen.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang oder beim Wasserlassen?
Nein, damit habe ich keine Probleme.
Sie hat sich Ihr Gewicht in letzter Zeit verändert.
Ich meine, haben Sie ungewirrt ab oder zu genommen?
Nein, gar nicht.
Das ist gleich geblieben.
Haben Sie Stress auf der Arbeit oder im Leben?
Haben Sie Probleme, die Sie belasten?
Nein, ich habe nicht.
Ich habe keine Probleme.
Ich habe keine Probleme, die Sie belasten.
Gibt es irgendwelche Medikamente?
Weil sie sich regelmäßig einnehmen?
Ich nehme sonst keine Regelmäßig Medikamente.
Aber manchmal nehmen Sie.
Rauchen Sie?
Nein, ich rauche nicht.
Früher haben Sie geraucht?
Nein, auch nicht.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Nein, ich trage es einmal, zweimal im Jahr.
Ein, zweimal.
Was trinken Sie gerne?
Ein, zweimal im Jahr.
Wenn Geburtstag oder Feier ist,
aber sonst nicht.
Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit dem Drogen?
Nein, mit Drogen habe ich keine Probleme.
Sind Sie allergisch gegen etwas?
Nein, alle gehen.
Keine.
Keine Unverzwecklichkeit.
Keine Bekämpfung bisher.
Danke schön.
Ich habe alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Würden Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Oder haben Sie Fragen an mich?
Nein, keine.
Keine Fragen.
Danke schön.
Ich würde gerne zuerst die Köpfe hervorlegen.
Dann rundherum ein Bild veranlassen.
Dann rücken.
Vielleicht handeln wir uns in zwei Ebenen.
Wenn es nötig ist,
würden wir auch eine MRT durchführen.
Darf ich mich eine Minute entschuldigen?
Mein Akku geht gleich.
Ich muss das anschließen.
Kein Problem.
Herr Schröder, ich habe etwas vergessen.
Ich habe etwas bemerkt.
Ich würde ein paar Fragen stellen.
Haben Sie ein Endegefühl im Brust?
Manchmal, wenn die Schmerzen sehr stark sind,
habe ich das Gefühl,
als wenn mir jemand die Brust ein bisschen einschnürt.
Ein bisschen.
Ein Endegefühl.
Wenn Sie Schmerzen haben.
Okay.
Und strahlen diese Rücken oder ihre Schmerzen
in irgendwohin aus?
Nein, die strahlen nicht aus.
Haben Sie etwas Auslösers bemerkt?
Nein, ich habe bisher nichts bemerkt.
Keine Auslöser.
Oder gibt es etwas,
die Schmerzen lindern?
Oder versteigt?
Nein, ich habe es mir nicht aufgefallen.
Danke schön.
Jetzt bin ich fertig.
Ich habe ein Kollege und andere Fragen.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Ich weiß nicht.
Herr Oberarzt,
ich würde gerne einen neuen Patienten berichten.
Ja.
Ich würde einen neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Michael.
Ist ein 56-Jähriger-Patient.
Das ist ein 56-Jähriger-Patient.
Ich könnte gerne einen neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Er hat sich wegen Rücken schmerzen und Hypoesthesie im rechten Hand vorgestellt.
Er ist auch IT-Spezialist. Er muss immer sitzen, sehr lange seitlang.
Deswegen kann das auch ein Auslöser sein.
Diese Schmerzen sind dumpf.
Unsere Patient hat 400 mg, hin und her, abgenommen.
Aber das hat nicht geholfen.
Die Frage nach Fieber wurde verneint.
Er hat seine Mutter an Mama gekartnet.
Sein Vater leidet an die Betüs-Miletus.
Die Mutter hat mal Brustkrebs gehabt.
Die leidet nicht mehr drunter.
Er hat nicht mehr geholfen.
Er leidet an die Betüs-Miletus.
Vegetative Anämnese sind unauffällig.
Er ist nicht schmerzlos.
Er hat keine Anämnistik.
Was haben Sie mit ihm gemacht?
Wenn Sie körperlich untersuchen,
dann können Sie sich eine Blut abnehmen.
Sie haben Blut abgenommen.
Die LDH ist hoch.
Sie haben eine Erfüllung.
Es gibt eine Impulomation.
Der Radiologe sagt, dass der Mann am Rücken eine Raumforderung hat.
Er nimmt nicht so viel Kontrastmittel auf.
Er weiß nicht, was es ist.
Er nimmt keinen Kontrastmittel auf.
Er hilft nicht.
Er zeigt nicht.
Er sieht neben dem Rücken im Muskelbereich eine Auffälligkeit.
Er zeigt den Patienten aus und stellt sich hin.
Er ist etwas fürrunkelmäßiges.
Er ist etwas, das sich entzündet hat.
Er hat Schmerzen.
Er ist etwas fürrunkelmäßiges.
Wir sollten noch mal hören.
Ich habe eine andere Frage.
Herr Kollege, wenn jemand nach seinem Namen gefragt wird, wie heißt er?
Er ist etwas fürrunkelmäßiges.
Ich habe ihn doch gesagt.